if you put on your
old
wise sage hat
uh what advice would you give to young
people today high school
maybe undergrad and college
about life so like career
having a career they can be proud of
or maybe a life they can be proud of
so
people can do whatever they want to be
happy right so there's not one way to do
it
i do think that some people
a particular type of people out there a
lot of people actually they want to have
an impact on the world that's how they
get a sense of fulfillment right
so i mean you need to have like health
physical health you need to have good
relationships like
there's lots of things but most people
want to do something important they want
to have fulfilling work a way that they
can feel like they're contributing
i think a lot of people young people
today are are thinking like
um
you know i should be an activist or
something like that
and there's people in the world who have
power and i and i don't a lot of people
who don't i don't have power and so the
way to change the world is to
you know um
speak truth to power or like criticize
power and
um
try to pressure them to change
to me i don't think that's the right way
to actually have an impact on the world
because
um
you know everybody has probably i think
people have more power than they realize
um and by the way it's easy to be a
critic
it's hard to actually change these
things and fix it and so um you'll get a
lot of accolades from friends and things
like that if you kind of go around
criticizing it you know it's easy to do
like everything is broken and could be
better
including you know stuff i'm working on
i i find like
it's so frustrating it's the million
things i want to be better about like
what we're doing in coinbase
um
so
be be the person in the arena you know
like that theodore roosevelt quote i
think he said it right like go chew
glass and stare into the abyss like if
you really want to have an impact either
join a company that has a mission that
is trying to fix the thing you're
passionate about or start start that
company if it doesn't exist or start a
charity if if it's not suitable to be a
company or whatever it is but
go try to be a part of this solution
don't
just you know criticize or be a part of
the problem
my hope is that um
more people can
you know um
realize that they they actually can have
a meaningful impact that way and i think
that
to me technology is actually one of the
most important ways to improve the world
like if if you look at
um climate change like a lot of the best
ideas like carbon sequestration all
these things it's a technology thing
right if you want to try to fix
education it's like look at like khan
academy and all the stuff going online
right if you want to if you want to fix
um
you know whatever transportation and
like um the financial system and global
freedom and like equality of all these
things like there's typically the way to
get
something changed in the world today is
with technology and so i do think people
it's very bizarre to me there's this
kind of like anti-tech thing going on
um look no nothing is perfect like if
you create something new and like tens
of millions of people use it or billions
people use it it's like
there's gonna be some bad people who use
it too okay and there's you know society
is complicated but like i think
most of these things have been net
positive because most people in the
world are good is at least my view
so yes we can mitigate like the one
percent of bad people trying to you know
abuse something but 99 of people in the
world are good and the way you can
improve the world is with technology
joining companies starting companies
that are working on the right stuff so i
hope
i hope more young people do that and
just
if you're not sure what to do like just
get started with anything that's how you
learn and basically have the optimism
that you have the power to do the change
so
yeah
it's it's easy to distract yourself by
being the critic
um that's almost like acknowledging to
yourself that that's all you can be
but
basically everybody has the power to be
the fixer
i like
chew glass and look into the abyss
um that's much more fun than it sounds
[Laughter]
uh what do you think is the meaning of
this whole thing why are we here
it's life
yep what's the meaning of life what's
this existence we got
you're trying to increase the amount of
economic freedom on this planet earth
trying to alleviate some of the
suffering yeah but
why i don't really think there is any
point to life um
you know
uh
somebody once told me um
you know if you go into these like kind
of really big existential questions
it can get a little scary because like
you you stare off the cliff and there's
like there's nothing there you know um
one this one person told me one time
they were like
you know brian you should you should
probably uh snorkel don't scupa
i guess and i think they were trying to
say like
i i some of my friends have done this
right they they'll go to like you know
epic meta meditation retreats and like
i'll they'll kind of come back with all
this
existential dread of like what's the
meaning of all and like
as far as i can tell we are just some
organic molecules in the ocean started
like dividing and replicating and the
selfish gene and all this stuff like
basically ended up here
and our only it's it's some kind of like
really naive algorithm that's just kind
of trying to get us to survive and
replicate and we have dna just like
every other animal and so we and we
happen to develop these like really cool
neocortexes and so now we're sort of
self-aware and we have all these big
questions
and maybe maybe we'll create another you
know as computers get better we'll
create the simulation inside our thing
and
um i think it's cool like we should
basically i just want to keep watching
the movie you know unfold that's part of
why i want to work on um like new limit
is really cool because it's help if
people can live longer whether that's
uploading their brain to the cloud or
um you know basically through we get
biology to work or the strong ai to work
or whatever one of those two hopefully
works out and then we get to we get to
keep watching the movie and see how it
all unfolds i think that's fun and so
i don't know if that's like an answer
but i guess i don't think there's any
real purpose so just try to have fun
well the cool thing is that uh we get to
write the movie as
as we watch it yeah
that's exactly right i mean that's like
the steve jobs quote and all that where
he's like everything around you was
invented by some somebody who just was
like that this was a crazy idea they
thought up so
once you realize you can kind of do
anything you want
um
then
that's what you start to go you start to
go try crazier stuff i mean what this is
another one of those areas where um not
to get too out there but like you know
when you're when i was i think you can
build your comfort zone around like
people being upset with you you can also
build your
your range of what you think is possible
right like
when i was a when i was in my 20s i was
like reading all these books about like
self-improvement and goal right how to
write down your goals and stuff and my
goals were like
someday i want to
make a hundred thousand dollars a year
or something like and that was
and you know um
and it seemed like a little outlandish
or what i wrote down these goals like i
want to own rental property or something
anyway
and i and then i slowly started to get
get some of these things done over a
couple of years and so i started to
think a little bigger
i remember one time i wrote down this
goal where i was like
what's the craziest thing i could think
of i was like what if i i want to write
i want to start a billion dollar tech
company
that's crazy and i had i had never
started like a million dollar tech
company or any any tech company really
so what business did i have writing that
goal down
i remember i wrote that on a piece of
paper like
like probably every day for a year or
something almost right i don't know if
it was every day but like i wrote it
down a lot and
and so little things started to happen i
was like all right well maybe i should
move back to the bay area from buenos
aires maybe i should
try to apply to y combinator or whatever
like and i started thinking about these
ideas and so whatever gets you fired up
it doesn't have to be like some company
goal or startup thing it could be
anything right
um maybe you want to publish a book or
like do something creatively or whatever
anyway
you you know i think like within
seven years
uh no it's probably more like 10 years
of me writing that goal down
um coinbase had a valuation over a
billion dollars
so it it was out of my realm of what was
even possible
and then
within 10 years you can you can
accomplish more in 10 years than you
think less than in a year than you think
so now i start now i'm like okay what's
the next goal what's the crate okay
maybe i want to get a billion people
accessing the open financial system
through
our products every day you know that
would be cool for for humanity and
that's a pretty crazy goal like there's
only eight billion people or something
right so one out of eight
um or maybe i can radically like if i
make some like the right investments or
whatever i can like help
radically extend human health uh human
health span or whatever right
um
so
try crazier stuff i don't know even if
it doesn't work like hopefully you'll um
you'll
advance the state of affairs like
something interesting will happen and so
most people today they look at they look
at people trying this stuff and they're
like oh my god they're so they're a
genius or whatever and it's like or
they're an idiot like one of one of the
two
neither one are true it's just like um
anybody can start by thinking about what
they want and then like
go for it and then once you get that
like go for something a little bigger
and like you just have fun with it and
the universe is a way of smiling
and uh helping you out if you just write
it down and and you dream big
yes there's something about just
karma about
the energy you put into this world
other people will help you out doors
will open you'll notice that the doors
opened
and you'll make you could actually have
a shot at making it happen it's a funny
world
yeah i mean i don't i'm not i don't
really subscribe to all like the woo
interpretations of this but my like very
rational brain interpretation of it is
that if you just wake up every day and
write down like what you want to get
done and towards your longer goals at
your larger goals it's just it's just on
your mind that day so you start to
notice opportunities and you think about
it more so so brian thank you for
dreaming big um thank you for doing what
you're doing doing incredible
engineering at scale
uh trying to help out people from all
over the world and uh actually helping
me personally get more into crypto
just because it's so easy
so um thank you so much and
thank you so much for giving your
extremely valuable time today to this
awesome conversation thanks for your
awesome podcast i i love it i listen to
it often
you